batista hulk hogan
and what would the princess bride be
without andre the giant anybody want a
peanut
oh yeah
and tyrus
now
now without wrestlers audiences would be
left thinking guys like robert de niro
are a tough guy
okay but i will give you this one john
cena did not come up with the famous
catchphrase you can't see me that he
actually stole that from gutfeld who
used that whenever he was standing
behind a seven-year-old
boom
boom boom all night boom boom
anyway maybe movies ain't your thing
okay but wrestlers can also write
ever hear of best-selling author mick
foley or good old j.r jim ross
or how about
the number one on amazon new york times
wall street journal best-selling author
tyrus
still not convinced did someone hit you
over the head with a steel chair
okay
well america loves olympians and we've
had mark henry ken patera kurt angle and
he won gold oh it's true it's damn true
we've had more takedowns than twitter
we have it's factual ever seen a gi joe
cartoon as a kid remember sergeant
slaughter
okay i get it this is a news network so
let's talk politics okay all right cool
jesse the body ventura he went on to
become governor of minnesota
and now one of the fastest rising voices
in the republican party is a former
wrestler mayor of knoxville your friend
in mind glenn jacobs aka kane
so wrestlers can talk to talk and walk
the walk unlike our current president
who can't do either without machines
matter of fact you can't even say the
american dream without someone saying
dusty rhodes
dusty always told me tyrus paint your
own canvas and when you hear the people
you'll know what to do and you owe me
money for all that i've taught you
open and shut like door right no still
not convinced okay okay
have you ever been out in public and
someone yelled whoa
and the people yelled back what whoo
why
because everybody wants to be the nature
boy
ric flair not joe who has the same
he has the same nickname but
for different reasons that h.r won't let
us get into
and wrestlers we're in more homes than
couches everybody wants to be a wrestler
actors singers boxers football players
last week kilmeade asked me to put him
in a headlock said it reminds him of
high school
muhammad ali don king president donald
trump they all learn how to talk trash
from what wrestling
the great guerrilla monsoon coined the
phrase the irresistible force meets the
immovable object well that also sums up
greg when he's constipated
bam all night told you all night
and when athletes win a super bowl or
nba championship they ask for what
a wrestling championship belt
[Applause]
now this sunday when i beat trevor
murdoch for the nwa world heavyweight
championship at the chase i'm not going
to ask for a damn trophy i'm going to
wear my trophy and i don't have any more
room for metal necklaces
still don't feel me okay okay i didn't
want to go there but here we go
the second most talked about president
of all time that freed the slaves saved
the union abe the hatchet lincoln ring a
bell
at four and 120 pounds he was huge for
the 1860s
so wrestlers are the very fabric of our
country and it's no wonder tyrus is
hosting the number one show
what you gonna do brother or woman or
person or we ain't got time for all that
the next time a wrestler walks by you
say thank you still want to tear your
shirt off and disagree i said old abe
was the second most talked about
president of all time because the
greatest wrestler to become president
who else president donald trump
and man can he cut a promo just like a
wrestler he's a villain he's a good guy
love him or hate him guess what you
still watch him and you see that's the
story of wrestling it's the same the
story of america individuals that beat
the odds tenacious gritty witty and
strong with all those traits there's no
goal you can't reach even if you're as
short as greg i told you all night
now who knows there could be a third
wrestling president
all right
let's welcome tonight's guest she's the
florida phenom active in the navy
reserves and you will get served morgan
the octopus ortega
representing the great outdoors the
arizona assassin nature girl katie
pavlik
from parts unknown weight unknown his
reasons for being here unknown
comedian joe devito
and like in ink cartridge she's small
colorful and hard to replace cat the
smitten kitten tip
or
catherine c catherine c tim
investigative journalists which you can
catch on the tyrus and tim podcast oh he
has to be a lot of plugs great plug yeah
so cat let me go to you for i know
because last night when you uh when i
was sending you ideas about my monologue
and stuff you did not know that abraham
lincoln was in fact a wrestler i did not
know that so i was like how much do i
not know about wrestling so i googled a
lot about wrestling oh boy so did you
it's the oldest sport ever so it's like
older than jesus that's a big deal um
and there was a guy named barry horowitz
do you know about this guy he had a
seven year losing streak and i thought
that was relatable because i had a seven
year losing streak like not in wrestling
but just ages 23 to 30. and
snooki she won more ppv wwe matches than
sting what can like what can snooki not
do um and i could go on for a really
long time but i won't
uh
but
like there's i just thought i just
thought it was people throwing chairs
and bret bear will not have you on i
know
i know i can do a special special
wrestling report
all right assassin now listen you and i
what we would call the tournament
wrestling have a small feud the last
time i was in the five she made fun of
my cardigan i did not she said it was a
sweater i accurately called it a sweater
material cardigan
which is basically saying
it's a sweater
okay so if you had to chew were you
shocked or surprised to hear that
president trump in fact was arrested i
was shocked and surprised about that you
know i used to think that wrestlers were
very short and stout and then i met you
and my mind was blown
but one of my favorite shop teachers in
high school was for welding i also know
how to weld in addition to being an
assassin uh he was a wrestler he was a
wrestling coach and he actually did
throw a desk across the room once and
then we didn't see him again
yeah i don't think anything to do with
wrestling yeah why i'm doing his
teacher's pay probably something like
that something like that i have mr parts
unknown you know a little bit of
everything i was
intrigued the fact that did you always
want to be from unknown
you don't have a choice when you're from
parts unknown it's great yeah there's no
taxes in unknown either this is so
strange i never thought there would be a
co-host or a guest host for the show who
would choke slam me in the green room
and uh i'm sorry about it well no well
that actually was last night when cat
was hosting
her pregame warm up isn't it that is
rough i actually hid in the hair and
dressing room while she was warming up
because
i you know my rep would have been gone
in seconds if you were to choke slam me
i mean people would start picking on me
all right octopus now you've you've
served you've been in close quarters
with me how much influence has wrestling
been in your life if at all well
everyone knows from my national security
beat that i'm such a big wrestling fan
and i'm sensing a little sarcasm not
really i remember in high school the
boys that wrestled um they all had like
ringworm and i thought it was really
gross that's what i remember in high
school
right everyone remember that
but here's the other thing that here's
my beef though with modern wrestling is
john cena does he count as like a modern
like today wrestler because all i know
is that he capitulated to the chinese
communist party and apologized in
chinese for talking for acknowledging
hong kong and taiwan
so this is how i relate to wrestling by
talking about china um
that is a strong argument my question is
you do you own an apple phone yes shut
up
[Laughter]
john cena is a saint
oh are you buddies with him
am i buddies with him
no after he said that stuff no uh he's
yeah no he's a good guy i liked him he
was a good friend he was fair to me
horowitz
no one no barry horowitz is a legend and
yes he did lose for seven years is he
jewish i love that we have a jewish
wrestler sure sure
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else